le décryptage avec vous je lui dis gloss
bonjour julie échanges pas évident parce
que c'est vrai que les deux hommes by
dane et poutine ont vraiment des
positions à l'opposé sur le cren
opposé chacun se sent menacé par l'autre
donc le principal point bien sûr qu'ils
aient discuté aujourd'hui c'est la
situation en ukraine et sa souveraineté
les etats unis l'otan et l'ukraine vous
l'avez dit accuse la rousse la russie
est bien de masser des troupes à la
frontière ukrainienne pour une
éventuelle invasion une éventuelle
attaque les chiffres avancés sont entre
90 milles et plus de cent mille hommes
qui seraient à masser à 7 à cette
frontière cela ravive bien sûr le
spectre de l'invasion de la crimée en
2014 sont encore la guerre dans le don
base de son côté lui vladimir poutine
dit s'inquiéter de l'expansion vers
l'est de l'otan mais comme ligne rouge
une éventuelle adhésion à l'otan de
l'ukraine ou encore de la géorgie qui
n'est pourtant pas à l'ordre du jour du
moins pas immédiatement dit s'inquiéter
du déploiement d'armes hostile envers la
russie dans les pays d'europe de l'est
est en réalité ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup de spéculations sur les
intentions de vladimir poutine
les différents observateurs sont très
divisés sur ses intentions est-ce qu'il
va vraiment intervenir ou pas et c'est
un coup de bluff beaucoup pensent qu'il
bluffe sans pour autant exclure
totalement une intervention ce qui
explique probablement et bien la
réaction préventive des états unis en
cas d'intervention les etats-unis ont
prévenu ils renforceraient la présence
militaire dans l'est de l'europe et
apporteraient leur soutien à l'armée qui
craignaient un d'intervention armée
directe mais un lot de sanctions
économiques qui pour l'instant pourtant
n'ont pas vraiment porté leurs fruits la
menace la plus importante que
brandissent les états unis c'est l'ex
l'exclusion de la russie du système
d'échangé d'informations bancaires swift
c'est un système qui relie 11000
institution à financière entre elle et
ça serait vraiment dramatique pour la
russie cependant très bien c'est une
décision que les états unis ne peuvent
pas prendre seuls ils sont obligés de
consulter les européens les européens
clés sont pour l'instant beaucoup à être
opposés de peur et bien de représailles
contre des petites entreprises
européennes en tout cas les russes eux
ont prévenu en cas d'une telle sanction
bien se serait apparentée à une
déclaration de guerre affaire à suivre
merci beaucoup julie